hero some folks definitions welcome to
our when it comes to the collision
between two worlds Capcom Zone versus
fighting game series is arguably the
best in the business it's been over five
years since we last saw Marvel's finest
go toe-to-toe with Capcom's beloved
franchises and now it's time for another
clash with Marvel vs. Capcom infinite so
what's changed what's new what crazy
mechanics has Capcom come up with this
time well keep watching to find out and
if you want more coverage of NBC and all
the latest fighting games don't forget
to subscribe to the GameSpot YouTube
channel because I guarantee you we're
going to have a lot more to talk about
in the future but for right now let's
get into what we know so far based on
the first trailer that we all saw back
in December Infinite will return to a
2v2 format which hasn't been seen since
the first Marvel vs. Capcom nearly
twenty years ago many people in the
Marvel community were hoping for
something just as hype and combo
friendly as MVC 3 woods but we had a
chance to check out the game at Capcom's
offices and by golly it's a different
beast altogether there's a lot to get
through so let's start off with the
basics
first off infinite has thrown the button
layout from MBC three out the window and
has returned to a four button setup
similar to MBC two punches and kicks
both get a light and hard variation but
characteristics a staple and the marvel
of franchises for decades are now gone
instead the final two buttons will be
used for tagging your partner and using
your infinity stone power now tagging a
partner will cause them to run on the
screen and you can immediately begin
attacking with them but what makes this
mechanic special is that you can tag it
anytime anywhere in the middle of an air
combo sure tagging your partner
throw a fireball and then immediately
tag in yeah you can do that activate a
hyper combo and then tag in and rush
them down with high-low mix-ups yes you
can do that too the game may lack this
but it makes up for it by allowing you
to essentially create your own no longer
will characters be thrown aside because
their assists are weak or be essential
to a team all of dr. doom because of
their versatility while this may seem
weird at first after all Marvel players
the world round loved their assist it
all plays into the main mechanic that
drives infinite combo system and if
Capcom statements about making the game
more accessible put you in a panic well
I can assure you that there's nothing to
worry about they have made the game
easier for casuals by introducing an
auto combo system that simply involves
pressing the light punch one mashing the
button won't exactly win you the game
but it's a smart move for people who
don't play religiously to stand a
fighting chance
and speaking of combos they're just as
deep and complex as ever ground balances
and wall bouncers make the return oh and
every single character can ocg by
themselves but there is a huge potential
for creativity when it comes to combos
in this game and we haven't even touched
on the insanity stones yet well actually
let's do that right now so each of the
six Infinity stones grant your character
in infinity search a special power that
you can use at any point during the
match
Capcom shows off three of the stones in
the build that we played the time stone
which gives your character a warp - the
power stone which gives you a
short-range wall bounce attack and the
space stone which allows you to suck
enemies in perfect for command grabs the
stones abilities are decently powered by
themselves but build enough meter and
you'll be able to unleash the infinity
storm effect the powered up time stone
speeds you
significantly throwing any recovery
frames out the window and allowing you
to chain together moves into custom
combos the power stone surge amplifies
our damage and gives every move you
connected with a giant ground or wall
balance but my favorite out of all the
three definitely has to be the space
stone surge which simply enough traps
your opponent in a giant box they can
still attack and block but they're stuck
there for a while just waiting to be
rushed down even by Marvel vs. Capcom
standards these stones are pretty insane
and honestly I don't think I'm going to
miss x-factor all that much oh and one
last thing you can say goodbye to one
player games because now whenever your
character is caught in a combo with
certain deaths on the horizon you can
activate a counter switch and what that
does is call in your second character
who you now control while your opponent
is beating up the first so this opens up
the game's defensive options while also
putting pressure on the attacker to
continue their combo or not it does cost
two super mirrors to activate the camera
switch but I take that over a dead
character any day now there's a lot more
I haven't mentioned and I don't really
want to drag this on too long so I'm
just going to do a rundown everything I
missed ready go rock Iraq who's in the
trailer but not playable on the latest
build so that does give me hope for a
Groot as a character at least the
footage here may not show it but if you
time it right
push blocking will actually reflect
projectile yep finally a counter against
Morgan doom
Ultron might be the only brand-new
character so far but everyone at least
feels slightly different from the
previous Marvel vs. Capcom iterations
and despite being beaten up in every
trailer that we've seen Mega Man
actually looks pretty cool his moveset
has a ton of awesome projectiles and his
ex armor actually powers them up
not unlike Arthur and finally ending
this on a weird little note dead
characters actually stay on the screen
for some reason maybe it's a distraction
or maybe it's an intimidation factor for
the other team I don't know it's kind of
weird it's pretty crazy that were
already less than five months away from
new Marvel vs. Capcom so as we get
closer to the September release we'll
have a lot more information about the
game so please keep it tuned the
GameSpot and subscribe to our YouTube
channel for all the latest of things
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]